el comunicado final de la reunión
subraya la oposición a las acciones
unilaterales provocadoras y coercitivas
que buscan cambiar el statu quo habla
también de la militarización de las
zonas en disputa y del uso violento de
la guardia costera no menciona a china
ni falta que hace porque detrás de la
organización está la voluntad de
embridar la expansión china en el lindo
pacífico beijing ha criticado la
organización como un síntoma de la
mentalidad de guerra fría de washington
y le ha calificado como de otan en el
pacífico es una etiqueta que seguramente
le viene grande porque no es una alianza
militar al uso no contiene elementos
como la defensa colectiva sino que es
más bien un foro informal que ha ido
evolucionando y fortaleciéndose con el
tiempo nació en el 2004 como respuesta
al devastador tsunami que asoló el
sudeste asiático y careció de relevancia
hasta que hace cinco años en la zona
creció la inquietud por la presencia
china y sobre todo por la construcción
de islas artificiales
la colección de
de los países miembros con china en los
últimos años ha acabado de fortalecer
una organización que junto con el august
simboliza la voluntad de estados unidos
de combatir a china en su patio trasero